hello everyone today i am here to
present my research project on the topic
surveillance of sars kovi 2 variants of
concern from wastewater samples
before going ahead
i like to
introduce myself my name is ritu sharma
i am a msc biotechnology student from
amity university noida
my field of interest is in genomics and
bioinformatics i have done my research
fellowship from pine biotic
the objective of my research project is
to learn and analyze variants of
concerns in wastewater samples and
perform msa and phylogenetic analysis
using ngs data employing t bioinfo
server
these are the list of content which are
included in the presentation
they are introduction data overview
exploration comparative analysis result
findings and bibliography
starting with introduction the
coronavirus which was the cause of
covet 19 pandemic which led to deaths of
more than 3 million people and
worldwide's health crisis
is mutating at faster rate and hence it
is important to understand its mutation
in the genome
the structure of virus has a lipid outer
envelope covered with spike glycoprotein
there are two types of protein present
in the genome of sars kovi ii
one is a structural protein which
encodes for four genes namely e for
envelop m for membrane s for spike n for
nucleocapsid gene at three prime utr
the non-structural protein which is the
second type of
protein present in the genomes of sarco
v2
majorly are the enzymes or functional
protein which are responsible for viral
replication and methylation and cause
and can influence responses to infection
by host
these genes are encoded in different
groups including orf1a orf1b orf3a orf6
orf7a orf7b
orf8 and orf10
the mutated or altered variants are more
transmissible can be more violent and
has strong ability to dodge the
responses of host
and poses greater challenge in clinical
and diagnostic management
but not all mutations lead to major
protein variations and altering virus
infectivity
the data set for different samples taken
for various studies are available on
ncbi we first extracted data from bio
project
prjep4191 from ncbi as our data set for
the project
we downloaded this raw data from sra run
table which contains samples from uk
in the original study authors performed
a longitudinal analysis in the month of
march to july in the year 2020 of sars
kovi 2 rna prevalence and sewage across
six major urban centres in the uk
by qrt pcr and viral genome sequencing
the result demonstrated that levels of
sars cov2 rna generally correlated with
the abundance of clinical cases recorded
within the community
with a marked decline in sars ob2 rna
abundance following the implementation
of lockdown measures
in their study
authors shown that the genetic diversity
of sars cov2 from wastewater suggests
that multiple genetically distinct
clusters were co-circulating in the
local population
covered by their
sample sites
and that the genetic variants observed
in the wastewater reflects similar snps
observed in
contemporaneous samples from cases
tested in clinical diagnostic laboratory
here we have taken 10 random samples for
our study
then we downloaded
a reference genome from ncbi in genbak
format
which is required for translation of
nucleotide to amino acid
this reference genome was the severe acu
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
to isolate from voodoo
this is the sre run table which is the
data set for our project
the 10 data the 10 samples which are
marked in the red
box are the 10 random samples we have
taken for our study
then we come to exploration that is
preparation for analysis
we learn that genomes equal the
different types of genome sequencing
that are targeted ngs sequencing it is a
rapid and cost effective way to detect
known and novel variants in selected set
of genes or genomic reasons
then is the whole genome sequencing
which provides a comprehensive picture
of information in the genome by reading
both coding and non-coding sequence
whole genome sequencing generates more
detailed look at information of our
dna then we come to whole exome
sequencing
which targets the protein coding regions
of the genome providing less coverage it
gives us information about the coding
regions of the genome
moving on to the variant calling so
variant calling refers to the task of
identifying possible variations in the
genome or transcriptome sequence with
respect to a chosen reference sequence
that there are two types of variant
calling first is a germline variant
calling this is the reference sequence
in which the variations are present from
the birth
these are not usually taken as the
reference
sequences
second is the somatic variant calling we
these are the variation which
occurs
with time and these are normally taken
as the control somatic cell sample
there are two types of
two methods by which
the sequence is read
one is paired in this sequencing is a
method in which reads are made from both
the ends and of each fragment towards
the center of the
fragment single end sequencing in which
each fragment is only red from one end
towards the other end
then we studied about phylogenetic
analysis so it can be performed to
understand the relationship among them
and their origin
it is typically performed analyzing the
genetic and molecular differences
between dna sequencing to determine the
evolutionary distance
there are different tree
representations in the phylogenetic
analysis the one you can see
in the picture is a dendogram
then mutability in simple terms describe
the observed rate of given position to
the change or mutate
differential mutation is an evolutionary
algorithm that processes a population of
individual represented by dimensional
vectors of real numbers
copy number variation is a phenomenon in
which sections of the genome are
repeated and the number of repeats in
the genome varies between individuals in
the human population
these are the various pipelines which we
have run for various analysis
that first one is gradient calling then
mutability analysis then phylogenetic
tree analysis and copy number variation
in our project we will look at
phylogenetic tree analysis
starting for starting our project
we need to follow five steps
first step is to
finding the data set which we have
discussed earlier how to find the data
set we downloaded the sra run table from
ncbi bioproject
then is the running msa and phylogenetic
pipeline using t buyer info server for
running the pipeline we have used tbio
infoserver and the figure shows the
pipeline graph which we used
so
following steps need to be followed in
the or in order to run the pipeline for
msc and phylogenetic analysis
first step is to selecting pipeline and
parameters
we select phylogenetic tree option to
perform msa and phylogenetic analysis
next step is to select the appropriate
parameters we have selected fastq format
as we are taking ngs data
then we have to upload the data
that is the sra run table
and the reference genome in the
respective columns and make the group
then we have to create the pipeline
first we will click on start button then
we will select the boutique under
mapping for aligning the reads on the
reference general
consensus module and per nuke module is
reselected for generating the consensus
sequence from ngs data and to generate
per nucleotide position respectively
then multiple sequence alignment was
performed on the consensus sequence
that is at nucleotide level and then at
the amino acid level
after completing the msa step a
phylogenetic tree was regenerated using
beast speciation birth death process
module
which is used by us there are other
methods also but we are specifically
using the b speciation birth death
process
and for ending the pipeline we will
click on the n button and name our file
subsequently
then the second step is finding the
lineage of the sample from sarsko
sars pangolin server
for finding the lineages of sample we
first go to pangolin
lineage.org
and we
upload the faster sequence for each
sample there and
click on run so we get the lineage
closest lineage for each sample
the next step is to finding the mutation
amino acid of the sample for that we go
to outbreak dot info side where
we can find the
mutation in the amino acid by
searching for the specific lineage which
we have got for each sample
after that we can find the mutation in
nucleotide sequence of the sample by the
msa table which we got pro as a result
of the
msa run
pipeline
now let's discuss the result which we
have got for different pipelines
the msa
msa and phylogenetic tree analysis
pipeline gave us this phylogenetic tree
which uh which contains the
closest evolutionary origin of
eight sample
with the pangolini age
written in front of them
we can see samples err 5019830
and
err5019834 are in the same claim in
phylogenetic tree and have closer
evolutionary relationship with the
reference genome since common node for
both plate also have closest common
lineage with b variant sample
err5019835 and
err5019840 are in the same clade and
also share close distant evolutionary
relationship with outgrowth sample
and also have closest common lineage
with b
0.1
other samples namely err5019837
err501
err5019836
and
err5019838 has different closest
lineages as b one b point one point one
b point one point one
point three seven two
b point one point one and b point one
point one
point one six one respectively and also
are in different clade as a result does
not have closer evolutionary
relationship with the reference gene
the next result is the mutation in amino
acid sequence of samples of different
lineages
so these are the five lineages
namely b
b point one b point one point one
b point one point one
point three seven two and b point one
point one
point one six one
which
which we have got for our ten samples
the result shows that most of the
lineage have common mutation in orf1b
orf
8 and ng
next result is for the mutation in
nucleotide sequence in msa table
so this is the mse table and we we were
finding the mutation in this table
we got this a few major
few major mutation at different position
at position three zero three
there the result shows mutation in
nucleotide sequence at position 3 0 3 7
and t and c basis
also the coverage for both are given
for both t and c it is given as 50
the next position is 9634 where we have
got the nucleotide
mutation
np and a bases
the coverage for both is given as 50
percent
the next position at which we have got
mutation in nucleotide sequence is at
position 14408
tnc basis
also the coverage for t is given as 57.1
percent and for c coverage is given as
42.9 percent
the finding the key takeaways which we
have got from our project
is genome genomic sequencing of sars
pov2 from wastewater has the potential
to be valuable tool in population-wide
moderate ring of circulating lineages
we analyzed uk seaweed waste water
sample to assess the sars cov2 variants
first we performed multiple sequence and
alignment and phylogenetic analysis
using t bioinfo servo we observe samples
are distributed in three clades
err5019830 and
three err5019834 are in the same plate
with the reference general
sample err5019835
and
err5019840 are in the same clade and
also share closer evolutionary
relationship with outgroup samples
whereas samples err5019831
err5019833
err5019836 and err 501983
with err5019838
and err5019839
form a distinct plate
this indicates there are most probably
different variants of sars kovi 2.
besides we also assess the number of
mutation in the samples in comparison to
the referential
we observed err50198637
have maximum number of mutations
that is 15 followed by err5019836
that is 12 mutation in comparison to the
reference general
while sample
five zero one nine eight three five have
minimum number of mutations that is five
mutations and err five zero one nine
eight three zero and er five zero one
nine eight three one has no mutation
we also got the mutation on gene of
samples and we found that most of the
mutation is seen on orf1b orf8 and ng
finally to confirm what variants these
were we generated sars cov2 variant
report for these samples we observed
that
err5019837 contained four mutation of uk
variant and two mutations of sa variant
whereas the
err5019834 sample contains none of the
mutations from these variants
besides we also analyze spike protein
variants in the sample here we found
five variables
these are the reference from where we
have
taken
we have uh studied for our biopro and
the for our research project thank you
you